il avait lancé le bras de fer ce matin
en bloquant la nationale 10 ils ont
finalement eu gain de cause après une
réunion avec le préfet des yvelines
le cirque nicolas zavatta douchez va
pouvoir s'installer au mois de février
sur l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines les dates seront définies dans
la semaine lors d'une rencontre avec les
responsables de la structure durant
cette rencontre à la préfecture les
acteurs du monde du cirque ont alerté
aussi sur les difficultés à exercer
leurs activités dans certaines communes
cette réunion une réponse à la
mobilisation d'une dizaine de cirque
lundi 17 janvier une soixantaine de
circassiens ont bloqué la nationale 10
dans les deux sens de circulation face à
la mairie de trappes leur message
continuer à exercer leur activité avec
des animaux c'est la liberté et du droit
du travail devant une mairie les
l'égalité et la liberté c'est pour nous
car plus aucun sens je suis quand on
rentre dans une amérique entendu comme
un des animaux c'est comme si on était
des voleurs ou des terroristes alors que
non justement on a des animaux passent
quand les m6 aujourd'hui comme pour
demain il n'y a plus d'animaux dans les
cirques excusez moi mais les cirques il
s'appelle cirque sans animaux pour nous
ce n'est pas des cirques il ya d'autres
formes de spectacles que j'ai très bien
mais le cirque traditionnel doit
continuer avec ces animaux si les
mairies font ça on sera obligé de
bloquer le monde du cirque doit faire
face aujourd'hui à la loi du 30 novembre
2000 21 visant à lutter contre la
maltraitance animale l'article 46 de
cette loi dispose sont interdits dans
les établissements itinérant la
détention le transport et les spectacles
incluant des espèces d'animaux non
domestiques
cette interdiction entre en vigueur à
l'expiration d'un délai de sept ans les
acteurs du cirque ont jusqu'en 2028 pour
faire face à cette transformation